[Music]
my name is Connor Moran I'm the director
of the Wisconsin Book Festival and I'd
like to welcome you all to what is
proving to be another wonderful day at
this our 14th annual Wisconsin Book
Festival thank you to all of you for
coming tonight or this afternoon I'm
delighted to be hosting Nicholas Carr
for his book utopia is creepy he's very
right but first I want to thank Madison
Public Library the Madison Public
Library Foundation and all of our
sponsors for making this possible I want
to thank you here in this room for
coming and also everyone watching at
home on c-span folk TV
cultural experiences like this are few
and far between and we are so honored to
be able to put one on for you over four
days here in Madison Wisconsin for the
past 15 years give or take Nicholas Carr
has been giving us the real alternative
history of what the information age
means for all of us if you've been
listening to him through his blog rough
type you have heard many different
things about the the personal rights and
privileges that we willingly give up
every time we turn on the phones in our
pockets which you should all turn off
now so that you don't interrupt next
tune tonight you have heard about how
the internet changes our brains and
you've heard many different other fairly
scary or creepy things Nick's here to
give us kind of a better view of how we
can live our lives in this technological
age and change the future of how we
interact with our technology please help
me welcome Nicholas Carr
[Applause]
thank you thanks very much
Thank You Connor and my thanks to
everyone involved in putting on the
Wisconsin Book Festival both for for
hosting such a my Mike's not on is that
better now in thanks to everyone
involved with the Wisconsin Book
Festival both for for putting on such a
terrific event and for secondarily for
inviting me to participate in it and
share some of my ideas in perspectives
with you this is my my new book as
Connor said it's called utopia is creepy
if you don't remember the title you can
just look for the book with all the
emoji on the cover I think in fact if
you if you added up all the emoji that
have appeared on book covers throughout
history they're actually more on my book
than all of those combined not sure
that's something to be proud of but it
is something the book collects a lot of
my shorter writing blog posts and essays
reviews that I've written over the last
dozen years or so I started writing my
blog back in 2005 and so in 2015 the
10-year anniversary I started going
through I decided to look back through
what I'd written and there was something
like they're close to 1,700 posts that
I've written so it took a while to go
through but what that exercise in
rereading the stuff really brought home
to me is is how much not only technology
has changed in that relatively short
period but how much our lives have
changed because of the technology if you
think back to 2005 this was a this was a
time when people were talking about web
2.0 the rebirth of the internet after
the dot-com crash and it was it was a
time before smart phones had appeared
before the iPhone before the iPad before
social media Facebook had just just
recently been founded and was limited to
a few kids at Harvard and now if you
look at it we most of us who carry
around smartphones the best evidence is
we we pull out our smartphone and look
at it and do something with it somewhere
between 100 and 200 times a day from
many people and for most young people
it's the very first thing they look at
in the morning when they wake up because
it's waking them up with its alarm and
it's also the last thing they look at
before they go to bed and if you add it
all up this is something that we're
interacting with or looking at every few
minutes of our waking lives so this is
something really new in the world
something new in media something new in
technology and I'm not sure we thought
deeply or critically enough about
exactly how it's influencing us and
changing our behavior changing the way
we act the way we think and as I as I
pulled together the book I began to see
a narrative in the pieces that I was
selecting and it was really a narrative
that in one sense is a meditation on
technological utopianism this belief
which is very very long-standing in
American culture that we advanced as a
society through the advances of
technology and there's a good part
there's a good element of technological
utopianism it encourages lots of
innovation
lots of breakthroughs and we've all
profited from that but there's a very
bad side as well
and that is it begins to make us think
that progress is really just
technological progress as long as the
next iPhone is coming out in a few
months everything's good everything's
moving forward and we lose sight of the
fact that technology and tools really
should be a means to an end means to
some bigger idea of progress social
progress cultural progress or whatever
and only by taking that broader view can
we look at can we take the right
perspective in judging technology in
judging the way it's designed what its
intentions are most of these things are
obviously designed by
by companies who are looking to make
money and also we can judge our own use
of it I'd like to read a couple of
sections from the book the first one the
first reading comes from it will be an
excerpt from the introduction which is
called Silicon Valley days and it gets
into some of those themes that I'm
talking about and tries to put what
we've seen over the last dozen years
into this historical perspective the
greatest of America's homegrown
religions greater than Jehovah's
Witnesses greater than the Church of
Jesus Christ of latter-day saints
greater even than Scientology is the
religion of technology john adolphus x
ler a man from Pittsburgh sounded the
trumpet in his 1833 Testament the
paradise within the reach of all men by
fulfilling its quote mechanical purposes
he wrote the United States would turn
itself into a New Eden a state of super
abundance where there will be a
continual feast parties of pleasure
novelties delights and instructive
occupations
not to mention vegetables of infinite
variety and appearance similar
predictions proliferated throughout the
19th and 20th centuries and in their
visions of technological majesty as the
critic and historian Perry Miller wrote
we find the true American sublime we may
blow kisses to agrarians like Jefferson
and tree huggers like Thoreau but we put
our faith in Edison and given Ford gates
in Zuckerberg it is the technologists
who shall lead us cyberspace with its
disembodied voices and ethereal avatars
seemed mystical from the start its
unearthly vastness or receptacle for
America's spiritual yearnings and tropes
what better way wrote cal state
philosopher Michael Heim in 1991 to
emulate God's knowledge than to generate
a virtual world constituted by bits of
information in 1999 a year
Google moved from a Menlo Park garage to
a Palo Alto office the Yale computer
scientist David giler Terr wrote a
manifesto predicting the second coming
of the computer replete with gauzy
images of cyber bodies drifting in the
computational cosmos and beautifully
laid out collections of information like
immaculate giant Gardens the millenarian
rhetoric swelled with the arrival of web
2.0 behold proclaimed Wired magazine in
in August 2005 cover story we are
entering a new world powered not by
God's grace but by the web's electricity
of participation it would be a paradise
of our own making manufactured by users
histories databases would be erased
humankind
rebooted the revelation continues to
this day the technological paradise
forever glittering on the horizon even
money men have taken sidelines in
starry-eyed futurism in 2014 venture
capitalist Marc Andreessen sent out a
rhapsodic series of tweets announcing
that computers in robots were about to
liberate us all from physical need
constraints echoing John Adolphus heed
slur and also Karl Marx he declared that
for the first time in history humankind
would be able to express its full and
true nature we will be whoever we want
to be the main fields of human endeavor
will be culture art Sciences creativity
philosophy experimentation exploration
adventure the only thing he left out was
the vegetables such prophecies might be
dismissed as the prattle of overindulged
rich guys but for one thing they've
shaped public opinion by spreading a
utopian view of Technology a view that
defines progress as essentially
technological they've encouraged people
to switch off their critical faculties
and give Silicon Valley entrepreneurs
and finance ears free rein in remaking
culture to fit their commercial in
interests if after all the technologists
are creating a world of super abundance
a world without work or want their
interest must be indistinguishable from
our from society's to stand in their way
or even to question their motives and
tactics would be self-defeating it would
serve only to delay the wonderful
inevitable the web's profits have had
good intentions but their assumptions
were bad they put too much stock in the
early history of the web when it's
commercial and social structures were
inchoate its users a skewed sample of
the population they feel failed to
appreciate how the network would funnel
the energies of the people into a
centrally administered tightly monitored
information system organized to enrich a
small group of businesses in their
owners the network would indeed generate
a lot of wealth but it would be
concentrated in a few hands not widely
spread the culture that emerged on the
network and that now extends deep into
our lives and psyches is characterized
by frenetic production and consumption
smartphones have made media machines of
us all but little real empowerment and
even less reflectiveness it's a culture
of distraction in dependency that's not
to deny the benefits of an efficient
universal system of information exchange
it is to deny the assumption that the
system in order to provide its benefits
had to take its present form late in his
life
The Economist John Kenneth Galbraith
coined the term innocent fraud he used
it to describe a lie or a half-truth
that because it suits the needs or views
of those in power is presented as fact
after much repetition the fiction
becomes common wisdom it is innocent
because most who employ it are without
conscious guilt Galbraith wrote it is
fraud because it is quietly in the
service of special interest the idea of
the computer network as an engine of
liberation is an innocent fraud
I love a good gizmo when as a teenager I
sat down at a computer for the first
time a bulging monochromatic terminal
connected to a two-ton mainframe
processor I was Wonder struck as soon as
affordable pcs came along I surrounded
myself with beige boxes floppy disks in
what used to be called peripherals a
computer I found was a tool of many uses
but also a puzzle of many mysteries the
more time you spent figuring out how it
worked
learning its language and its logic
probing its limits the more
possibilities it opened like the best of
tools it invited in rewarded curiosity
in the early 90s I launched a browser
for the first time and watched the gates
of the web open I was enthralled so much
territory so few rules but it didn't
take long for the carpetbaggers to
arrive the territory began to be
subdivided strip mauled and as the
monetary value of its data banks grew
strip mined my excitement remained but
it was tempered by wariness I sensed
that foreign agents were slipping into
my computer through its connection to
the web what had been a tool under my
own control was morphing into a medium
under the control of others the computer
screen was becoming as all mass media
tend to become an environment a
surrounding an enclosure at worst a cage
it seemed clear that those who
controlled the omnipresent screen would
if given their way control culture as
well computing is not about computers
anymore wrote MIT s Nicholas Negroponte
in his 1995 bestseller being digital it
is about living by the
turn-of-the-century Silicon Valley was
selling more than gadgets and software
it was selling in ideology the Creed was
set in the tradition of American techno
utopianism but with a digital twist the
valley i'ts were fierce materialists
what couldn't be measured had no
meaning yet they loathed materiality in
their view the problems of the world
from inefficiency and inequality to
morbidity and mortality emanated from
the world's physicality from it's about
embodiment in torpid inflexible detained
stuff the panacea was virtuality the
reinvention and redemption of society in
computer code they would build us a new
eden not from atoms but from bits all
that is solid would melt into their
network we were expected to be grateful
and for the most part we were our
craving for regeneration through
virtuality is the latest expression of
what susan sontag in on photography
described as the american impatience
with reality the taste for activities
whose instrumentality is a machine what
we've always found hard to abide is that
the world follows a script we didn't
write we look to technology not only to
manipulate nature but to prospect but to
possess it to package it as a product
that can be consumed by pressing a light
switch or a gas pedal or a shutter
button we yearn to reprogram existence
in with the computer we have the best
means yet we would like to see this this
project as heroic as a rebellion against
the tyranny of an alien power but it's
not that at all it's a project born of
anxiety behind it lies a dread that the
messy atomic world will rebel against us
what Silicon Valley sells and we buy is
not transcendence but withdrawal the
screen provides a refuge a mediated
world that is more predictable more
tractable and above all safer than there
were calcitriol world of things we flock
to the virtual because the real demands
too much of us I think as I as I thought
back about my own
changes in my own attitude toward
technology computer technology in
particular which is of course what we
what we mean by technology today I've
come to I've come to the conclusion that
all technological enthusiasts as I once
was
are fated to end up either disillusioned
or delusional I did I think delusional
would be more fun
unfortunately I've become disillusioned
which at least as the events would be
more honest I think one of the but one
of the dangers of becoming disillusioned
by technology are beginning to see that
it isn't having the effects that many
people intended but is having very much
mixed impacts on us encouraging this
culture of distraction rather than
encouraging us to think deeply or to in
encouraging kind of a more polarized
view of the world rather than expanding
our boundaries and encouraging us to
look at other people's points of view
and so forth one of the dangers of
becoming a skeptic is that it becomes
all too easy to become a cynic and start
to look with a very jaded eye at all
technological advances and in recent
years I've struggled more and more with
this tendency and and in particular I've
tried to figure out I tried to draw a
distinction that works in my own mind
and maybe works for others about about
the types of technology that do what we
want great tools to do for us which is
open the world more fully to us in our
intentions expand our horizons give us
new ways to look at society communicate
with each other
examine the natural world in
technologies that have the opposite
effect technologies that close down the
world to us that don't encourage us to
explore that don't open new horizons but
rather constrain our horizons and I
think I fear that for all the other
benefits we get from it the technologies
the computer technologies we are
first in today social media smartphones
Facebook and so forth I think
unfortunately they're of the latter kind
we spent so much time gazing into
screens ever-shrinking screens in fact
that we quote we do close ourselves off
from a richer engagement with the world
and end with each other as I as I
thought about this I began to write an
essay recently it was actually started
off as a part of an earlier book I wrote
called the glass cage and it's an essay
that is inspired
strangely enough by a by a Robert Frost
poem more than a hundred years old a
poem is called mowing a sonnet and it
was a poem that's always meant a lot to
me ever since I read it when I was in
college but as a work of art as a work
of poetry and I began to realize that
maybe as I thought about it's more that
maybe it was something more than that
maybe it was a way to make sense of
technology it's all about a person
mowing a field of hay with a scythe and
so this this turned into this
realization turned into an essay that
draws its name from a line in the poem
the essay is called the love that lays
the Swale and rose and I'd like to read
a part of this essay to you because I
think it at least to me it goes beyond
any kind of either immediately positive
or immediately negative reaction to
technology it does try to figure out
what is it what qualities of a
technology or of a tool make them make
that particular technology meaningful
and useful to humanity in better our
lives rather than narrowing our lives
down there's a line of verse I'm always
coming back to and it's been on my mind
more than usual these last few months
the fact is the sweetest dream that
Labour knows
it's the second to last line of one of
Robert Frost's earliest in best poems a
sonnet called mowing he wrote it just
after the turn of the 20th century when
he was a young man in his 20s with a
young family he was working as a farmer
raising chickens and tending a few apple
trees on a small plot of land his
grandfather had bought for him in Derry
New Hampshire it was a difficult time in
his life he had little money in few
prospects he had dropped out of two
colleges Dartmouth and Harvard without
earning a degree he had been
unsuccessful in a succession of petty
jobs he was sickly he had nightmares his
firstborn child a son had died of
cholera at the age of three his marriage
was troubled life was peremptory Frost
would later recall and threw me into
confusion but it was during those lonely
years in Derry that he came into his own
as a writer and an artist something
about farming the long repetitive days
the solitary work the closeness to
nature's beauty and carelessness
inspired him the burden of labour eased
the burden of life if I feel timeless
and immortal it is from having lost
track of time for five or six years
there there he would write of his stay
in Derry
we gave up winding clocks our ideas got
untimely from not taking newspapers for
a long period it couldn't have been more
perfect if we had planned it or foreseen
what we were getting into in the breaks
between chores on the farm frost somehow
managed to write most of the poems for
his first book a boys will about half
the poems for his second book north of
Boston and a good number of other poems
that would find their way into
subsequent volumes mowing from a boys
will was the greatest of his dairy
lyrics it was the poem in which he found
his distinctive voice plain spoken and
conventional and conversational but also
sly in dissembling to really understand
frost to really understand anything
including yourself requires as much mr.
trust as with many of his best works
mowing has an enigmatic almost
hallucinatory quality that belies the
simple and homely picture it it paints
in this case of a man cutting a field of
grass for hay the more you read the poem
the deeper and stranger it becomes I
will read the poem now mowing there was
never a sound beside the wood but one
and that was my long scythe whispering
to the ground
what was it it whispered I knew not well
myself perhaps it was something about
the heat of the Sun something perhaps
about the lack of sound and that was why
it whispered and did not speak it was no
dream of the gift of idle hours or easy
gold at the hand of fate or elf anything
more than the truth would have seemed
too weak to the earnest love that laid
the Swale and rose not without feeble
pointed spikes of flowers pale or Kasese
and scared a bright green snake the fact
is the sweetest dream that labor knows
my long side whispered and left the hay
to make we rarely look to poetry for
instruction anymore but here we see how
a poet's scrutiny of the world can be
more subtle in discerning than a
scientists frost understood the essence
of what we now call embodied cognition
in the meaning of that heightened mental
state we termed flow long before
psychologists it neurobiologists
delivered the empirical evidence his
mower is not in airbrushed peasant a
rustic caricature he's a farmer a man
doing a hard job on a still hot summer
day he's not dreaming of idle hours or
easy gold his mind is on his work it's a
bodily rhythm of the cutting the weight
of the tool in his hands the stocks
piling up around him he's not seeking
some greater truth beyond the work
the work is the truth the fact is the
sweetest dream that Labour knows frost
here is not romanticizing some distant
pre technological past although he was
dismayed by those who allowed themselves
to become as it would later write
bigoted in reliance on the gospel of
modern science he felt a kinship kinship
with scientists in inventors as a poet
he shared with them a common spirit in
pursuit they were all explorers of the
mysteries of earthly life excavators of
meaning from matter they were all
engaged in work that extends human
dreaming for fuller frost the greatest
value of the fact whether apprehended in
the world or expressed in the work of
art or made manifest in a tool or other
invention lay in its ability to expand
the scope of individual knowing and
hence open new avenues of perception
action and imagination technology is as
crucial to the work of knowing as it is
to the work of production the human body
in its native unadorned state is a
feeble thing it's constrained in its
strength its dexterity its sensory range
its calculative cross prowess its memory
the body quickly reaches the limits of
what it can do but the body encompasses
a mind that can imagine desire and plan
for achievements the body alone can't
fulfill this tension between what the
body can accomplish and what the mind
can envision is what gave rise to and
continues to propel in shape technology
it's the spur for humankind's extension
of itself and elaboration of nature
technology isn't what makes us posthuman
or transhuman as some writers these days
suggest it's what makes us human
technology is in our nature through our
tools we give our dreams form
we bring them into the world the
practicality of technology may
distinguish it from art but both spring
from a similar distinctly human yearning
one of the many jobs that the human body
is unsuited to is cutting grass try it
if you don't believe me what allows the
mower to do his work what allows him to
be a mower is the tool he wields his
scythe the mower is and has to be
technologically enhanced the tool makes
the mower in the mower skill in using
the tool remakes the world for him the
world becomes a place in which he can
act as a mower in which he can lay the
Swale in rows this idea which on the
surface may sound trivial or even
tautological points to something
elemental about life in the formation of
the self the body is our general means
of having a world wrote the French
philosopher maurice merleau-ponty in
1945 our physical makeup the fact that
we walk upright on two legs at a certain
height that we have a pair of hands with
opposable thumbs that we have eyes which
see in a particular way that we have a
certain tolerance for heat and cold
determines our perception of the world
in a way that proceeds and then molds
our conscious thoughts about the world
we see mountains as lofty not because
mountains are lofty but because our
perception of their form and height is
shaped by our own stature we see a stone
as among other things a weapon because
the particular construction of our hand
in arm enables us to pick it up and
throw it perception like cognition is
embodied it follows that whenever we
gain a new talent we not only change our
bodily capacities we change the world
the ocean extends an invitation to the
swimmer that it with holds from the
person who has never learned to swim
with every skill we master the world
reshapes itself to reveal greater
possibilities if
becomes more interesting and being in it
becomes more rewarding technology by
enabling us to act in ways that go
beyond our bodily limits also alters our
perception of the world and what the
world signifies to us technologies
transformative power is most apparent in
tools of discovery from the microscope
in the particle accelerator of the
scientist to the canoe in the spaceship
of the Explorer but the power is there
in all tools including the ones we use
in our everyday lives whenever an
instrument allows us to cultivate a new
talent the world becomes a different in
more intriguing place a setting of even
greater opportunity the value of a
well-made and well used tool in other
words lies not only in what it produces
for us but what it produces in us at its
best technology opens fresh-ground it
gives us a world that is at once more
understandable to our senses and better
suited to our intentions a world in
which were more at home used
thoughtfully and with skill a tool
becomes much more than a means of
production or consumption it becomes a
means of experience it gives us more
ways to lead rich and engaged lives not
all tools are so congenial some deter us
from skilled action the technologies of
computerization and automation that
holds such sway over us today
rarely invite us into the world or
encouraged us to develop new talents
that enlarge our perceptions and expand
our possibilities they mostly have the
opposite effect they're designed to be
disinviting they pull us away from the
world that's a consequence not only of
prevailing design practices which place
ease and efficiency above all other
concerns but also of the fact that in
our personal lives the computer has
become a media device its software
painstakingly programmed programmed
to grab and scatter our attention as
most people by now know from experience
the computer screen is intensely
compelling not only for the convenience
conveniences it offers but also for the
many diversions it provides there's
always something going on and we can
join in at any moment with the slightest
of effort yet the screen for all its
enticements in stimulations is an
environment of sparseness fast-moving
efficient clean or revealing only a
shadow of the world that's true even of
the most meticulously crafted
simulations of space that we find in
virtual reality applications such as
games architectural models
three-dimensional maps and the tools
used by surgeons and others to control
robots artificial renderings of space
may provide stimulation to our eyes in
to a lesser degree our ears but they
tend to starve our other senses touch
smell taste and greatly restrict the
movements of our bodies when we enter
the virtual world were required to shed
much of our body that doesn't free us it
emaciate sus the real world in turn is
made less meaningful as we adapt to our
streamlined environment we render
ourselves incapable of perceiving what
the world offers its most ardent
inhabitants like drivers following GPS
commands we travel blindfolded the
result is existential impoverishment as
nature in culture withdraw their
invitations to act and to perceive the
self can only thrive can only grow when
it encounters and overcomes quote
resistance from surroundings wrote the
American pragmatist philosopher John
Dewey in art as experience continuing
that quote an environment that was
always in everywhere congenial to the
straightaway execution of our impulsions
kind of environment that software
programmers like to build for us would
set a term to growth as
sure as one always hostile would
irritate and destroy impulsion forever
boosted on its forward way would run its
course thoughtless and dead to emotion
I'm going to skip a section and go to
the end technology is a pillar in the
glory of civilization but it is also a
test that we set for ourselves it
challenges us to think about what's
important in our lives to ask ourselves
what human being means computerization
as it extends its reach into the deepest
spheres of our existence raises the
stakes we can allow ourselves to be
carried along by the technological
current wherever it may be taking us or
we can push back against it to resist
invention is not to reject invention
it's to Humble invention to bring
progress down to earth resistance is
futile goes the glib startrek cliche
beloved by techies but that's the
opposite of the truth resistance is
never futile if the source of our
vitality is as Emerson taught us the
active soul then our highest obligation
is to resist any force whether
institutional or commercial or
technological that would in feeble or
enervate that soul one of the most
remarkable things about us is also one
of the easiest overlook each time we
collide with the real we deepen our
understanding of the world and become
more fully a part of it while we're
wrestling with a challenge we may be
motivated by an anticipation of the ends
of our labor but as Robert Frost saw
it's the work the means that makes us
who we are
computerization and automation sever
ends from means they make getting what
we want
easier but they distance us from the
work of knowing as we transform
ourselves into creatures of the screen
we face an existential question does our
essence still lie and what we know
are we now content to be defined by what
we want thank you we have a we have time
for questions or comments because this
is being broadcast please if you if you
have a question come up to the
microphone so I think what the story
that utopia is creepy tells and it's
kind of a story that plays out in real
time as I was writing about these
phenomena is a story about what I see as
a basic and I think in some ways tragic
shift in the nature of what the personal
computer is or was up until about 2005
up until the arrival of social media and
what was then called web 2.0 a computer
was a tool or more accurately a set of
tools that each of us could use to
accomplish certain things and in many
ways it represented the best kind of
tools that are available to us it opened
up new areas of reading it allowed new
ways of communicating with different
people and it provide all sorts of tools
for photographers and musicians and and
pretty much everyone who could sit down
and do new things with the with the
computer but as the model of how
computing was delivered to us began to
change and this was really right around
2005 the computer was transformed from
being essentially a tool to being
essentially a medium and you can see
this not only in the way we use it the
way we're constantly looking to the
screen for diversion and entertainment
among many other things but also in the
way that the companies who began to gain
power and control over the computer how
they made money it was no longer about
selling a decent piece of software
decent program to you that you could
evaluate and use the way you wanted
it was all about selling advertisements
that would be shown to us and that that
changed the way the computer industry
thought about us their customers we went
from being tool users that we had to be
that that the companies had to show us
products that actually were valuable
enough that we would pay for them to us
being people whose attention they wanted
to capture and then resell to
advertisers and I think if you if you
look at the way in particular the
smartphone and apps and social media
like snapchat or Facebook or whatever
how they are designed they're very much
designed to keep us going back over and
over again to look at the screen
because what these companies understand
is that we are by nature human beings
are distractible we want to know
everything that's going on around us and
this you can you can see how why this is
so and this has been documented in
studies of the brain that show for
instance whenever we're searching for
getting a piece of information there's a
release of dopamine in our minds
dopamine being a pleasure producing
chemical very important to brain
function but also implicated in most
kinds of addiction we want to know
everything that's going on around us
because in the early history of the
human race that helped keep us alive you
wanted to know you want to see the
predator before it jumped on you you
wanted to see the berry bush that would
provide your meal for the evening what
we've done though now is develop this
new environment this new digital
environment that surrounds us more and
more all the time and it's an
environment that has been designed to
have endless amounts of new things
happening all the time and so it's no
surprise that given that and we walk
around with it in our in our pocket
these days we're constantly tempted to
pull out our phone and look at it simply
because we know that there's going to be
something new there and so these
companies and I I'm not I'm not
disparaging them but they make useful
Goods useful services and they're
they're doing what companies do which is
finding out ways to make money but these
these companies are very much
now in the business of keeping us
distracted and keeping us more and more
dependent on the software and the
services that they provide and in order
to in order to resist that and I think
it is important to at least become aware
of how our minds in our behavior are
being manipulated to resist that is not
simply to be a Luddite or to be a
nostalgia it's not about throwing away
your smartphone or shutting down your
Facebook account though if you do that I
would applaud you it's it's really about
trying to take back the technology as a
tool that we make deliberate choices
about how and when we use it and not
assume that it's in all-purpose medium
that should be surrounding us all the
time and that is necessarily good for
everything that we now depend on it for
um question hi thank you so much for
coming and speaking to this afternoon I
just kind of have a comment I can only
speak on behalf of my perspective and
what I know from my experience in the
world but I do agree with you there has
to be a lot more accountability on our
part as users I do also agree that there
is a lot of influence in terms of
manipulation because of what these
products can do but I also believe that
with the accountability and I'm once
paying from my generation as a
millennial there is a certain level of
consciousness victims with understanding
how this technology works and if you use
it you can create a forum and almost
like an opportunity to connect people
together and then you can use that as a
tool or a segue to getting together IRL
but I really think it's kind of
generational I don't want to speak and
say it's Millennials against baby
boomers or anything like that but I
really do think that Millennials embrace
the technology obviously a lot more and
apply it to avenues in terms of growing
as opposed to just
saying it's distraction I mean I do
spend a lot of time on Facebook but I do
spend a lot of time connecting getting
information I do feel that dopamine
release but at the same time I can use
that to be more productive in society so
I think it's about accountability I mean
we can say that it's so distracting but
we're the ones who are sitting there
looking at it as long as we use it to
our benefit yeah no and I think that's
absolutely a fair and valid point that
that that I've been focusing on being
critical of the technology because I
don't think we are critical enough but
that that doesn't discount the fact that
it that our smartphones and Google and
the internet gives us access to tons of
information that used to be very hard if
not impossible to get access to it also
allows us to communicate in ways that
used to be impossible or or at least
very very difficult I'm not my problem
though is is that I'm sure there there
are many people who use the technology
thoughtfully and wisely and I'm sure you
are one of them but if you look at the
studies that have been done the broad
studies have that have been done about
how people behave around their
smartphones and how they behave around
Facebook you don't see a lot of
thoughtful thoughtful consideration what
you see is this kind of some people have
compared it to what what we get what
people get when they play slot machines
essentially the a smartphone becomes
this kind of reward device that we know
that whenever we look at it we may get
some reward somebody may have liked
something we put up on Facebook or
retweeted a tweet we have in this is a
very powerful way to manipulate people's
attention is to give them this sense
that any time they they pick up this
screen they might get a reward and and
so I think even as we acknowledge the
great benefits we do receive I think it
is important because we've never had a
technology that is
so intrusive into our lives it is very
very important that we stand back and
look skeptically at what it's doing to
us as well as what it's doing for us
yeah thank you so I'd like you to put
your futurist hat on a little bit I have
been noticing in my life how TV went
from being a medium where my eyes were
being sold to now I'm paying to use it
as a tool I watch it when I want to I
don't watch any advertisements and I pay
a fee and I was wondering if that's
where we're hopefully headed with the
tech that you that you're taking issue
with yeah a very good question because
because it and this is something that
this is something I also write about in
the book that that the whole the whole
momentum of digital technology has been
toward giving stuff away for free the
expense coming from the desire to
capture our attention and show us
advertisements and television has taken
the opposite Road we now pay for
television
rather than most of us rather than
getting it over the airwaves for free
and it's very interesting to contrast
the two with TV as soon as people
started paying for it it started to
become really interesting and we got
there's still a lot of garbage of course
but it's we get you know very deep kind
of compelling narratives now that are on
all sorts of programs and I think it is
very much connected to the fact that
when we started paying for it it
relieved a lot of studios and a lot of
channels from the need to just grab our
attention in the simplest way possible
so that we'd stick around and hopefully
you know not head off to the kitchen or
the bathroom when the ads came on and in
with digital technology which which
often a lot of these companies you know
if if you ask Google or Facebook how
they conceive of themselves they'll
think of themselves as operating are
much higher plane than something like a
television studio but in fact I think I
think the
very much in the business though they
don't like to admit it of doing whatever
it takes to get us to go back to the
screen because that's how they get
information about us and that's how they
have opportunity to show us ads will
that change I I think there are some I
think there are some small indications
that people might be getting tired of of
this model of constant distraction and
constant dependency and so I think
there's at least a group of the
population that is probably in this may
continue will probably begin to back
away from the free stuff that we pay
such a high price for online and begin
to pay for more thoughtful things we can
kind of see that in the limited success
that some newspapers and magazines are
having with having people pay to get
unlimited access to their content but
how unfortunately my future has had its
pretty ill-fitting so I have trouble
seeing I it's a big enough challenge to
figure out what's going on at the moment
seeing ahead is really difficult so I
can't I can't say I'm optimistic but I
have seen in just the the years I've
been writing a kind of a shift from a
view that I got to get the latest gadget
I got I've got to load up every app I've
got a you know use every social medium
possible to among among more and more
people a sense that maybe this isn't in
my best interest and maybe if I actually
had to pay something out of my pocket I
could make wiser decisions about how I
use this very very powerful technology
whether that view expands broadly in the
population I don't know I mean my hope
is that we'll see a countercultural
movement rise up in question the
technology and as is always true with
countercultural movements that almost by
definition will mean young people
beginning to question the technology but
you know whether that is enough to
balance the momentum that things like
facebook and other social media have I
don't know it's very hard to tell um let
me let me in then if there are any other
questions with a brief with something a
brief I wrote oh okay great I'm in my
50s and obviously not a member of the
digital generation I find that I used to
have great focus and now especially when
I'm online I don't and it's very it's
frustrating are there any plans for I
don't know who would regulate this but
for companies to change the way they
present their webpages so if you click
on an article for example it's the
article and it doesn't have 26 different
links on the left and ads down the right
and stuff across the top and it's just
the article so for that few minutes you
can focus on that one thing and then
move on to the next ad they want to show
you why bad news for you yes the answer
is no back in in 2008 I wrote an essay
for the Atlantic magazine called is
Google making us stupid which is which
is in this book as a matter of fact and
it was all about that because I had
noticed that in myself as well that the
more the more time I spent online and as
I say this is really before smartphones
even took over Facebook or whatever but
the more time I spent online the less
able I seem to be to muster strong
concentration so I go away from my
computer and sit down to read a book or
a long article and I'd find myself after
a few paragraphs or a few pages kind of
getting nervous because I wasn't getting
enough stimulation I wasn't getting all
those links and those ads and wasn't
able to Google stuff every two seconds
and get lots of messages and I'd find
myself drawn back to the computer and I
think that does show that that our
technologies particularly the
technologies we use to think would do
train us to think in particular ways and
we adapt to them and I think if you look
at brain science and
governments have been that have been
made about neuroplasticity the way our
brains do adapt to our environment very
very readily you begin to see and I
think it's kind of scary that we are I
think adapting to this digital
environment that bombards us with
stimulation bombarded constantly
encourages us to shift our focus and as
a result it becomes harder and harder to
turn off that stream of information and
quiet down your mind to read something
or to have a conversation with somebody
without both of you you know glancing at
your phone or thinking about glancing at
your phone or listening to a piece of
music or walking in nature or the city
or you know even just following your own
train of thought so to me I don't think
barring some change like I talked about
I don't think we're going to see you
know companies like Google and Facebook
and Apple and Amazon stuff move toward a
quieter display of information where
you're not constantly encouraged to
shift your focus because that that would
defeat their business they make their
money by keeping you clicking and
shifting your focus all the time
so I think it comes down to really you
know a couple of things one is changes
in our personal behavior making sure
that we spend at the time and making
sure that our kids spend time not
looking at a screen and that doesn't
mean as I say that doesn't mean throwing
out the technology but it means
exercising your mind in different ways
and doing it kind of on a daily basis
where you where you keep training
yourself how to pay attention because it
turns out we're not good at paying
attention you really do have to train
yourself but I think it also means at a
societal and cultural level challenging
the huge importance we've placed on the
technology today you know if you want to
do something involving the government
you have to go online if you want to you
know if you want to hold your job you
have to be constantly monitoring email
and other messages if you're at school
all the assignments and stuff are given
out online we've as a society we've sent
this message to everybody that everybody
should be online as much
as possible and you can hardly live now
without doing it and I think beyond
personal discipline as a society we
really need to start thinking about you
know is this really the way we want to
live in the way we want to think one
more edit comments so I posted an
article recently on a blog about the
debates which was actually quite serious
and then a friend of mine saw the blog
in Holland and he was given a link to
like a really funny satire of the
debates and I thought was really
interesting because he said to me that
article you wrote was so funny and it
was because he was fed this alternate
content and it is really struck me that
you know these people like Google are
actually changing the meaning of
publications and I was just wondering if
you had any comment on that or if you've
witnessed it yourself
I mean I've certainly you know witnessed
dude as a as a writer in in and there
are both good things and bad things I
mean you know I say I've written a blog
for a long time and I've written in many
other for many other publications and on
the one hand you get you can get if
things get picked up and go viral a much
broader audience and you can you can you
know that you're getting the audience
because you get feedback on the other
hand it becomes harder in many ways to
make a living as a creative person
because we've begun to accept that we
shouldn't have to pay for this and so as
a writer I've seen for instance my the
pay scale for writing for newspapers and
magazines go way down because plenty of
people you're competing against all
sorts of people who are doing it for
free that's not a bad thing but it does
change the economics not only of writing
but I think of any kind of creative
pursuit in a very fundamental way one
more yeah
thanks for having this discussion I
think that's the exciting part about
technology is having a self reflect and
I there's a show I think it's Netflix
glass mirror have you seen that I've
heard about it I highly recommend if
you're interested in sort of questioning
technology's influence on our lives it's
really like Twilight Zone but it's all
focused on technology and it's just sort
of a short jump into possible future so
it's really a great way to that art is
helping us reflect on this exact thing
so thanks well and one of the reasons I
I call this utopias creepy there's
there's a there's a blog post in here
that's titled that utopias creepy is
that I began to realize that in art in
literature or
TV or movies its portrayals of dystopia
the horrible future that are really
compelling and that we'd like to watch
when you see when you see a when you see
a portrayal of utopia in the future it's
always either really boring or really
creepy because in order to be utopia of
all the kind of emotions and flaws that
that are intrinsic in being human and
our part of being human have to be
removed in order for it to be utopia so
so you realize that the utopia that is
often presented to us and that I think
the technology industry wants is really
at you tope utopia geared for robots and
not for human beings
so I I'll end it there thank you thanks
[Applause]